welcome to you around eight recap of the  2014 us chess championships well the  leaders have extended their lead on the  men's side Grandmaster version of Kobe  on one a nice game against Sergey  ehrenberg after the game he seemed cool  calm and collected I just didn't go  there just trying to win just try to  play good good chess good moves and if  you do that then you have good chances  to win and in the women's section  anisette on ski extended her lead by  defeating Alyssa mella hina the Queen  got on the board owner took her bishop  and left her with nothing to fight with  after the game unamused on her great  rivalry against arena crush coming up in  the next round I didn't play like  serious just over here and she's a  little more up to date I think she will  try to do something in openness may be  surprised me be sure to join us for  exciting action here in st. Louis at the  u.s. chess championships at one p.m.  Central at us chess james Kalm